problem number twenty at a local
bookstore books that normally cost B
dollars so they normally cost B are on
sale for $10 off the normal price so not
just $10 it's $10 off the normal price
so if the normal price is B so B is the
normal price the sale price is $10 off
the normal price or B minus 10 is the
sale price how many dollars does it cost
to buy three books on sale so each book
on sale is going to be B minus $10 so if
you buy three of them you just multiply
that times three so it's going to be
three times B minus 10 and you see that
choice right there now they didn't write
it like this if they multiplied it by
out you would just distribute the three
so it'd be three times B which is 3 B
minus 3 times 10 or 30 but that's not
one of the choices right there and then
lucky for us this choice is there 3
times B minus 10 B minus 10 is the cost
of each book on sale $10 off the normal
price problem 21 problem 21 if a line
passes through the points a and B shown
below so this is a and this is B
approximately where does the line cross
the x-axis approximately approximately
so they just want us to get a sense so
they're talking about this line let me
draw it here this line right there and I
just keep going like that doing my best
to draw it straight if you had another
pencil you could actually draw it
perfectly and so where does it cross the
x-axis well I way I drew it it does
cross the x-axis right there so let's
see which of these say that so between
minus 3 and minus 2 well yeah that's I
mean just the way I drew it this wasn't
exact but that looks pretty good so I'll
underline this there are some other
choices that were close to that I'd have
to be a little bit more exact let's see
what the other choices say between 0 and
-1
well that means here and it clearly the
line didn't cross anywhere near there so
that's definitely not our answer between
0 and 1 the line was nowhere near there
so it's not there between 1 & 2
clearly not than so this was so we can
be very confident that our choice is a
out of all of the choices that's the one
that even gets close to where even my
rough drawing cross the x-axis is
actually even my rough drawing did go
right between minus 3 and minus 2
problem 22 which expression is
equivalent to this thing right here so
let me rewrite it so we have 7 times a
squared times B times 7 times B times C
squared so when you have multiplication
it's actually commutative you can switch
the order of multiplication so if we
just switch the order of this we could
say this is the same thing as 7 times 7
times a squared right 7 times 7 that's
that right there and then you have times
an a squared that's that right there and
then you're left with this these two B's
so you could say times B times B C
squared right that that is that right
there and so we can just rewrite this 7
times 7 is 49 a squared is just a
squared B times B is B squared and then
you have a C squared so it's 49 a
squared B squared C squared which is
choice C 49 a squared B squared C
squared